-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night".
We hope you're all doing well.
And now, we re going to
get to the news.
During an event yesterday,
celebrating the
Affordable Care Act,
President Biden welcomed
former president Barack Obama
back to the White House
and said,
"Feels like the good ol' days."
Yeah, I'll be it does.
The good ol' days when you were
just going out for ice cream
and riding shotgun on the
Hope and Change Express.
Sucks when the responsibility
is all yours, doesn't it?
Turns out,
there's a world of difference
between taking an Uber
and driving an Uber.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
is set to sign a bill today
that will increase the financial
stability and reliability
of the US Postal Service.
The bill is called the
Pottery Barn Act of 20222.
Ivanka Trump reportedly
met yesterday
with the House committee
investigating the January
attack on the Capitol
for nearly 8 hours.
Oh, my God, you guys.
She did it!
She worked an 8-hour day!
[ Laughter ]
I knew she could!
I knew she could.
A man on a Southwest Airlines
flight was arrested
over the weekend
after he was allegedly
caught masturbating on board.
He was caught after passengers
heard clapping
before the plane landed.
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
the second season of
the Netflix series "Bridgerton"
was watched for more than
250 million hours
over the last week,
which is a record
for the most-viewed
English language show,
even though most people
watched it on mute.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, today was
National Walking Day.
This news first reported
by a sign in the subway.
And that was a monologue,
everybody!